hey everybody and welcome to a dope wild
ride with stevo we've got hannibal
burris this week he's a legend of comedy
and now he's going for it in music
with the name shoe tune so we're talking
about his transition into music we're
having a laugh about all the crazy stuff
he's been a part of and it is a really
good time plus i want you to know that i
felt great while we talked to hannibal
burris because i got such a good night's
sleep right here on my tour bus on my
mattress from helix sleep.com now i'm
guessing that a lot of you have
disgusting old mattresses that need to
be changed and
they're probably not even that good for
you because
if you go to helixsleep.com you take a
two minute quiz it's super easy and they
actually match you up with the perfect
mattress for you
and your partner if there are two of you
in bed it couldn't be better to get the
best mattress for you and if you go to
helixsleep.com
stevo you get up to 200 off any mattress
you buy plus two free pillows telling
you man i love my helix mattress and you
will too so go to helix sleep.com
stevo for up to 200 off any mattress and
two free dope pillows so jump on it and
let's get into it
because then if you're doing them too
much you ain't got a [ __ ] you ain't no
[ __ ] to say
yeah yeah sure you all burnt if you
doing them you're like oh what's in the
news today
every story
yeah
is
it's just made you know
and then it
yeah
because even without doing mine
i didn't want to be
now
because then you
start talking about too much you know
what i'm saying and talking about too
much and then and now even with the
we're doing music
i i try to put my stories in there or
save little things for that and then and
then you know i could talk through that
in a
you know and work on it and
and get it right all right so this is
your camera okay if i want to ham it up
yeah maybe like a little more in the
corner i think because
here we go cool
and uh we'll
fire it up did i hit the i stopped the
generator it sounds like you did yeah
sounds yes okay good all right
all right
ladies and gentlemen hannibal burris
what's up man yeah dude how's it going
dog so you're doing great so you've met
my co-host scott randolph yeah the
gorgeous paul briskey yeah
producer editor
um man thank you for doing this dude
we're both on the road right now yeah
you've just performed at
t payne's wiscanson fest
wiscansen fest okay
and probably some people would be
surprised to know that you did
music there not common well comedy music
the music yeah yeah music i mean some of
the songs have a funny right like
element but i'm not
leaning
right right right right i apologize for
trying to stuff you into comedy yeah but
we did listen to it and uh you know like
the judge judy song is hilarious thanks
man that one
that when i was
judge judy i put that out and i'm like
what was that that's really that song is
only i only made that song because my
i didn't like how much my mom liked
watching judge judy i didn't get it
it's addiction yeah because he was like
it's not it's no
but i guess the the
how predictable and comfortable it is is
part of
the appeal for sure but that's what it
was like it's like she's just
condescending to people over
small civil disputes over and over which
is fine to knock it out but uh you know
i appreciate the
the structure and the business but she's
also the richest huh she is the
wealthiest television personality in the
history of the world i i believe that
big what like more than oprah for real i
did syndications i think
which makes sense do you saw a youtube
video that said
uh rob durdick makes
like
125 000
per episode of ridiculousness and
they're in like
i mean dude how many [ __ ] episodes
it's insane so i think judge judy is
kind of like
that you know death by a million pen
pricks
i watched the video
it was a video popped up on youtube
breaking down
how rob did it it was a lot of stuff too
yeah
with the title of it was uh how rob rob
durdick has controlled mtv for like 15
years i sent that to my niece and nephew
he's an impressive guy man
yeah it was broken i was like oh i
didn't know
because you know the persona
and the business behind it is is two
different things oh i didn't know you
know he he made the moves
like that and then especially when
you've got something that's
this easy easy to produce right and you
have fun doing it if i
knock them out and re-up and then dude
they knock out like six episodes a day
yeah and they do that like day after day
it's insane and you see on tv that's all
the place
i was on uh
chanel west coast she had like this live
stream she invited me on and i had just
watched that video and i was like man
did you see this video like
and i'd said like 125 grand per episode
and she was like
because she's not getting 125 grand she
has said as much that she did not yeah i
mean i don't know who knows and and
she's just not she's having a baby so uh
congratulations to her
um
but
okay so i only have one bill cosby
question and that is how sick of bill
cosby questions are you
it's uh
you know
i mean that blew you up
okay
okay like i had my you know i had my
path before that i mean
it blew me up it made
people wear me in a way that
right they wouldn't have
and
honestly i didn't like being found like
that by some people because it takes the
it
the it takes the the other stuff is sure
of mine isn't that in the same tone you
know what i mean was like i haven't
worked i was on my
second special at the time you know
working and had stuff it's just a
it's an interesting situation man it's
been going for a while like if i i
didn't know that i'd still be right yeah
wow
i don't want to even get into it
is a
is a fair question yeah
people or people starting to look at you
as like you're the take down comedian
like who are you going to take down next
or like things like that i get those
messages sometimes like this is a good
get him on a case
like hannibal he's out like what are you
gonna do now oh yeah
yeah like this rolling thing of every
time i knew a new part and then it would
be a new
new people that
find out about it did also get angry it
was it's interesting because now it's uh
you know right
it it makes a template for
how
some folks communicate with me on the
internet that's really what that is and
i've heard a bunch of different verb but
i know
it's either somebody will say this
yeah and
but it's funny with people with fresh
anger
about it too
oh okay yeah yeah that's how i heard
this version in
2014 you're this you this robot it's
it's probably similar to jim jeffries
and his gun control bit
like that
that's that that blew up and so he goes
on tour and like half the audience is
there because of this like woke like gun
control thing and then they get just
like
like right right we don't want to say
that
but yeah
um now you
i i heard from our our uh
mutual friend adam
and as it was happening he was so
excited he says hannibal's gonna put his
new special out on youtube
and like this is such a disrupting move
like with
you know
just letting netflix know that hey you
guys
like
people are people are gonna just put
stuff out on their own yeah and
he was really excited about that and
described you being wildly successful
with
with doing that and last night i wanted
to to watch it so i looked it up i tried
to find it on youtube and it's not on
there anymore i took it down yet okay
yeah at what point
uh
later in 20
the reason so i was actually
i had a deal with
it was about to go up on netflix
uh
miami nice
in 2020.
and
it was a lot of that was you know
pandemic time so i was chilling
it was a lot of time to think on [ __ ]
and
i'm like oh maybe i should do it
independent because it wasn't no gigs on
the horizon right right you know created
a lot of
short-term thinking for me
uh
and so i pulled it they were in the
midst of doing their metadata like
closed captioning and stuff like that's
where we went out with that closet huh
yeah yeah we was like paperworks but
then i just sitting around the crib ah
nah and not to say that i regret it i
regret doing it like that
after being that far in the process with
him but it was it was a fun it was
just a product of being at the crib and
making that move whereas if i was on the
road
it definitely would have went up on
netflix because it wouldn't have been no
time to even
just well it's interesting that you
describe it that way because i uh
understood that you were like the poster
child for
like successfully
disseminating your own special on
youtube like uh because you know some
people have done really well with it
some people haven't yeah i was happy
with the special the special's gone you
know if i put it back out or whatever
where do people find it now
it's just not out like i just uh i like
i might put it back out or
we'll see maybe you know
i let my daughter handle it and some um
it's just i took it down it was also
really weird putting out a special
during that time
because
you know everything was shut down so it
was none of the
usual movements
that come with
with doing a
special or a promoting special there was
no party there was no
show you know what i mean
it was weird doing it even
i did some press but it was all zoom
i did daily show that felt weird
to do television
from my place because then you wired
afterwards i think i did tv but right
right
cause it's those even the movements that
come with that getting in the car going
there saying what's up to security you
gotta die you get your little snack you
know
you get your mic on you've gotta die you
leave wind down
all these different you know pieces to
that to that process it was like nope
just talk to the
camera in your crib right and then you
just there
wired after it was uh it was weird man i
threw a party
because uh
i just couldn't
say so this was
july
but i think that's july 3rd i think i
put out the spousal july 3rd
i threw a party
on my roof uh
july 5th because
i just i needed to
have i needed to have some energy i had
a band there and and and then but then
more people came and i thought and this
was at the the super spreader time
cove it panning panic right right was
probably more
uh
you probably catch it more now
man
uh like numbers wide but it was just i
remember and i took a little shroom
and then
this i shouldn't have taken the strings
because then
they hit and i started being like
i got all these people in my place and
it's covered time
they're gonna call me a super spreader
this is a super spreader
oh [ __ ] i'm about to buy you and all
this father go terrible
and then i just
i just shut it down i went
i went up to the roof
well i don't forget i forget who's on
drums but i'll get up to the roof i'm
like
shut it down
party's over guys party's over y'all i'm
panicking right now you said you'd
forget who was on drums
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think yeah this uh chrome
sparks was produced he produced uh judge
judy he was i don't know if he was on
drums if he's on keys at the time but he
features on us soon
too
uh he made the beat he's a dope producer
i found him through uh
he had this track that popped up
on pandora once called marijuana they
held marijuana by chrome sparks when
that first when i first heard that i
remember i was in airbnb in charlotte
when i heard that and it probably it was
one of those where you just you know i
listened to that probably
50 60 times
over and over but certain songs just you
know i i get obsessed with them uh
and uh yeah it samples this older song
by idris mohammed uh
what is the name of it but the the
drummond on that is really
[ __ ] chrome sparks uh
that [ __ ]
it is a great track yeah [ __ ] yeah
i think
i misunderstood something about your
music that i want to clarify we heard
hannibal burst is making music so i
looked up hannibal burris on spotify
yeah there's judge judy there's these
songs but you have tuned that's your
tone yeah which is
serious
more serious or not goofy music some of
them some of them are goofy some of them
are regular yeah yeah yeah okay but i
just wanted to clarify that so there's
youtube which is where the
i was showing you the wrong [ __ ] is that
what you performed last night yeah yeah
performing those laughs you're on the
bill as shoe tunes yeah i guess you too
and i put it actually to an ak handle
because perfect you know yeah
you know
hannibal helps get him in the door sure
[ __ ] now i want to say too that as i was
looking for your miami nights special on
youtube and was unable to find it i went
through like what looked
like
a a legacy of stand-up i mean you got
clips that are like
nine years old seven years old like with
like
millions of views and you know i i
watched him you got a new one that just
got posted i think it was posted by
comedy central yeah get to know hannibal
in uh like eight jokes and they got like
eight full bits oh yeah
yeah i watched it like uh
i really enjoyed it man i i
legitimately enjoyed it and i was struck
by like the
the variety of the different venues that
they had you performing it like from
small to to huge and it was good it only
just came out three weeks ago and so
it's a rad like snapchat of your whole
stand-up career and
clearly
uh illustrates what you were saying
about how man all that bill cosby [ __ ] i
had everything going already you know
like it's evident from when i went
through your youtube clips man thanks
man yes it was uh
now because i've been really
entrenched in music
and so
i started i hadn't i don't watch a lot
of my oh stand up and ask when we were
in the studio working on something i was
telling the story and i pulled up some
and it was it was like watching a
different dude you know what i'm saying
i was watching live from chicago
and the blaze around and i uh
fake glasses
uh because i had lasik at the time but i
was like uh they saw me with glasses so
i should wear glasses
because i'm old now my [ __ ] vision
fell off a cliff and so i need glasses
but so much of the time like people
aren't used to seeing me glasses i gotta
i gotta not film with them
you know like it's a trip and now i'm
self-conscious because uh
the glasses in the store that fit the
best are the [ __ ] same ones knoxville
words all the time so i feel like a
knoxville dick sucker i've seen things
like you guys are turning into the same
person right it's awful but
in any case so
you're you're so into music now yeah
like you're not even doing stand-up
you're just out performing music yeah
not really man not really performing a
stand-up
i'm a
special occasion standard
okay like if a good friend really want
me to come or uh
if they if they hit the number
then uh
there's a number but yeah on the casual
side as far as just
i don't have that energy where
right how i used to just pop up and [ __ ]
and just like really or try to do
three shows at a night whatever like
that that ain't really happening anymore
do you have even like a note in your
phone of like if you think of a bit or
it's so outside your mind that has two
raises okay
i come up but i just it's just i can
still do it in the music show because
it's right you know what i'm saying is
just making it put it as the banter in
between right in between songs and [ __ ]
my favorite one i've done
come over recently is that
i got baby daughter as uh she won and we
she met my my sister and brother we all
we were at my sister's house in phoenix
and so
she was around uh outlet you know
and
they get
you know everybody get word to the baby
by the outlet
um but if she ain't got nothing in her
hand
her finger can't just fit in the outlet
i get i understand the concern but it's
not real
dangerous at that point but
that sounds like potential for a rad
[ __ ]
you know my baby she just trying to get
her superpowers right now over there
yeah it's an origin story right yeah my
baby origin story
let life
yeah
yeah
so when you say that you'll do stand up
if they hit the number yeah like
presumably the number dictates like what
what the
what the plan is and so i kind of take
that to mean the the getting booked for
music is hitting the number
what hannibal's about to say about
performing music really makes me respect
him as an artist and i've always
described myself as a guy who distracts
people from their problems i'm an
entertainer i'm not going to fix your
problems but i'm going to distract you
from them and i think that's a noble
cause but let's talk about actually
addressing our problems because that's
pretty important too and i've been doing
that in therapy i'm happy to admit it
it's very helpful and my primary concern
in therapy is making sure that i improve
and
make my relationship with my fiance more
joyful more healthy and it's working
great man and so
on top of distracting people from their
problems i actually want to help people
address their problems by giving them a
great way to get into therapy because
it's so helpful and the folks at
betterhelp.com
are sponsoring this episode and giving a
generous offer to the wild ride
listeners by offering 10 percent off
their the first month if you go to
betterhelp.com
stevo that's better h e l p dot com
slash stevo and you get ten percent off
your first 30 days i'm telling you it
couldn't be more simple couldn't be more
worth it and they have a whole network
of super qualified therapists and they
easily match you up with exactly what
you're looking for so jump on this go to
betterhelp.com
stevo and i really think it's going to
help you as it is helping me
so
let's talk about the numbers
is that right no no like i'm in the
passion mode with music
you get me show up to music
like i'll just you know if it makes it i
i'd like to
i do want to make money from i do but
it doesn't have those same barometers
because i'm in the mental
this my state of just
of grinding and having fun so it's
working up obviously i have some
advantages you know
but it's not the same it's still you
know some some growth to do so it's like
it's exciting even you know doing the
festival yesterday
i was on at 4 25 you know what i mean
because i'm a
new musician but
now you're going to see it because i'm
kind of a pothead
not like hardcore like 425
and so it was but it you know
folks was there and it was it was
exciting to
to do it and i was i was worried at
first but because of
my experience seeing festivals and
outdoor festivals where people you see
those daytime sets and like yeah
but it was indoors milwaukee and you
know
it was packed and it was it was fun but
yeah so music [ __ ] for now
um yeah i'm down i'm down to come
through and and rock out just because i
i enjoy it so much it's so interesting
that
like you
are you're really a legend of comedy
going into
music and like i'm coming from some
other [ __ ] into comedy so we're a little
similar in that yeah and you gotta it's
just uh
you gotta retrain people and just just
like you know like you got to get doing
this right
hey no for real i'm doing this like you
know what i'm saying you got it and it's
it's different tools you used to do that
you got your bus where you like hey we
rolling through look
we in your city god damn it like even if
you even if they ain't see uh the ad
online or they ain't get the email from
the venue you're like i saw that
[ __ ] bus so
let's see what the hell are you up to
here in wausau you know
is you gotta you gotta you gotta push it
it's definitely it's going to see how
many days y'all spend on the where i go
this year on the road
i mean i haven't counted three on two
off three weeks on two weeks off is the
goal yeah
everybody you know it's we're hitting it
pretty hard yeah hitting it super hard
for sure do you have any shows coming up
soon or do you have anything on the
books i got adult swim fest august 6th
uh
are you gonna philly you're gonna what
are you gonna do there i'm doing music
there okay with strong banter in between
songs strong band
yeah i do comedy i do strong banter now
yeah wow
and then in chicago i'm doing a
silver room block party
which is uh yeah a silver room is a dope
store
run by eric williams and silver block
party is a chicago institution
that they've been doing for years it's
the first time they're charging for it
they're having it on the lake so
uh i'm performing there
and uh
might be doing some shows with fellaini
he's doing united center i think the
july 14th
16th round in
and so those uh
yeah coming up and [ __ ] man where's home
for you
home right now l.a oh yeah cool home is
la and i'm in chicago some yeah
okay
yeah like i i'm
i don't know why i feel nervous but like
wait was it at all controversial leaving
the eric andre show
no not controversial
it was uh
the reason i left was because
it was a gap in between
that just felt
a bit
unnatural to to me for to jump back in
okay uh like because the the first four
seasons were boom boom boom boom right
and then it was just it wasn't happening
um for a bit
and so then
i thought it i thought the show wasn't
happening anymore right which is fine
too you know
and so then
going back in
uh
yeah it didn't feel
because out of rhythm you know what i'm
saying that you know it's a lot of
things you do in that that amount of
time and so right it's just jumping back
in didn't feel it
did that did eric get you into um
meditation
no
i mean i know he was he was he
definitely was doing a lot during breaks
uh
i haven't i don't meditate
like i should i'd be getting in my
[ __ ] head space app and then not
really using it to what the money i
spent on it
i do it's upside but yeah you know i try
to
definitely lately i've been trying to
you know with my mornings trying to get
like you know make sure i do
dope [ __ ] right before i get into the
internet yeah they're getting so i you
know my best mornings is when i get up
you know
write some [ __ ] right away or listen to
oh like you know i'll go into
my studio
um
like if i go do something in every
little room that got something in it
like i got my synth in one room so like
if i before i end and you know even just
playing something that even not even for
the purpose of making a song but just
like having fun
and then going to the room with the
drums
going into this other room say something
then go into this other room write
something down got a pretty dope ass
house huh
all these rooms yeah yeah you got a
little
you know space to move around a little
bit
and you know you know read a book but
just maybe read two pages of a book and
write something and then go to go in and
try to just stretch out and and then
i'll those will be the best days of [ __ ]
and trying to you know and then as far
as making something right away
when the brain is is pure one morning
i was like i started when we i was
listening a lot of brazilian music
and then it was one song
that came on on this playlist
um
by uh
zaka veloso or something but this is
this is real
he's singing in portuguese about his
the song is about a boy needs his mother
but it's like super slow and he's like
singing in his hype
and it just
hit me
in a way and i just started writing this
this song to it
and i never had something take over my
day like that where it was just i got a
[ __ ]
and it was the whole day right now and
something usually when i write or finish
songs with other people involved but
that one was like i gotta [ __ ] in
i'm supposed to see my daughter that day
i didn't go see her i was just
just i was just in it man and it took
over the weekend too where i was just
this this song just hit but it was
because it was
you know one of the first things that
happened that morning it was i didn't
you know i hadn't communicated with
anybody yet
that like that song hit my brain fresh
and it just like it hidden away
um and i wrote
some of them like you know most personal
[ __ ]
they ever wrote and that's like a a rap
a song you're writing yeah song i wrote
gotcha yeah
and are you like uh on your new stuff
are you producing some of it to me
because you said you're messing with the
synth of stuff are you working with the
producer on uh
the first
four tracks on the esc tune so one three
pocket veneers
uh
and
but i was at the airport
and
one other
i
co-produced on those
stuff yeah cause that's
that's one thing too
because when it when when you try to go
into something in the music
and uh people try to say
like okay you like but the uh the beat
was dope so i just was like is it did
that's the view so much of him like yeah
i made the beat too
oh he got carried by the beat yeah that
was me also
what's the sample in that song there's
that like
repeating sound there's like a chick
yelling
what is that example
is uh
it was this uh
video i saw on twitter
when his lady was snapping on
uh
she was the manager of uh uh mcdonald's
and she was i don't know what happened
before but she was yelling at some
customers and that was a insult so she
was it was a manager of a mcdonald's
saying
and so burger king mcdonald eating ass
[ __ ]
and so
and so i uh just thought that was
hilarious
and then we had a session book later
that day true was my engineer and uh
shalik also produced on it
and i like i don't know we making today
but this is the sample
we're starting we're starting with this
yeah and we did it and it was like let's
make the track you know
from
chicago has uh
his footwork music which is you know
real
it's kind of
you know eating edm is a cousin of it a
little bit like just
really produced and and high bpm
so we're trying to make that yeah is it
it's more of a drumming bass sound now
but that was one was just
you know making these these type of
tracks that just start yeah
like hectic and overwhelming and just
really really grabbing and they work
live well because you have to
bring the energy performing right it's
like it's a super intense track and yeah
a lot of the the other producers like
that track a lot too and a few they're
like oh that's my [ __ ] because it's just
yeah you know it grabs you it's not
isn't that passive yeah yeah it's
different i like it that's paul man he's
a big musician over here yeah i produce
music too yeah maybe that's why i like
that one so much yeah because i'm so
talented
yeah
we
just yesterday set up this bus with uh
sonos oh yeah yeah and the first thing i
looked up was uh his music and then the
second thing we looked up was your music
oh word yeah um when you take a sample
from twitter like that it sounds like it
came from twitter like is there are you
just rocking it just throw it in like or
maybe it's just so yeah did you have to
pay for that
i'm gonna find that lady like this yeah
i'll find out
like it's not it hasn't gone up i've
gone crazy yet the music
like kanye west samples stuff like like
he's got that little kid in the car was
like like yes god and like doing that
whole thing he like cut the whole thing
out like yeah did he pay them for that
he's definitely paying because he got a
different uh light and lens on him yeah
right right me and it might it might be
a slow burn but i i want to because she
inspired me so i want to handle handle
that [ __ ] you know right properly and
i gotta believe that the uh
sampling judge judy's voice
is potentially more of an issue
i think it's safe to say that getting in
trouble with judge judy might be bad for
your health but what is incredible for
your health is athletic greens ag-1 baby
comprehensive and convenient daily
nutrition here i am on my tour bus when
i wake up in the morning i dump a pack
of this into my water i pound it it's
delicious it's loaded with 75 different
vitamins minerals whole food source
superfoods probiotics adaptogens i mean
it's really really delicious and very
good for you it fills in the gaps in
your diet and let's face it we're not
all eating enough greens and such on top
of being so nutritious it helps your gut
health it helps your brain
i mean i really really love this company
and they really really love the
listeners of the wild ride podcast
because if you go to
athleticgreens.com you're going to get
five of these packs free plus an entire
year's supply of immune boosting vitamin
d
with your first purchase it's just a
dope deal so go to athleticgreens.com
stevo try this stuff out you'll see what
i'm raving about you'll see why i use it
every morning and it's a great deal
athletic
athleticgreens.com
stevo now let's get back to it
i don't think you didn't sample her
voice yeah she's in there oh yes
she's in the track big time oh she's
gonna get her money
i just take that [ __ ] right down i don't
like the song
you're like sir
i think she
i don't think i think
she's like 88 dude she doesn't know what
the [ __ ] going down
and dude you know i'm so fascinated by
her because um
i i i got a little side gig going on
it's not even a gig but i got into
tattooing people i just i thought it
would be funny if like what if i
put the maximum effort try my ass off to
do the best tattoos and in doing so
i at least surprised myself with what i
was able to just train it well how long
did you train or i got i got it i got a
buddy of mine he's been a pro tattooer
for 20 years
and he just like under his supervision i
just gave it all yeah yeah and and
the last tattoo i did was we have back
up man
the training the training was six
minutes we're excited
how long did you what was the prep
before you did the first one oh well the
first one i mean it was just like
i do meet and greet after my shows so
like
bring their own needles
was that the first tattoo you gave where
you spelled your name wrong was that the
very first one very first one i ever did
was uh yeah the one where i spelled my
name wrong you did that on stage i did
it on stage
like i was told i had some show way back
in 2005 i think it was 2006. and it was
2005. and um some
like this they were like some guy wants
to uh get a tattoo
they're gonna wheel a tattoo
stand like a trolley out with all the
equipment on it and just just do it and
i was like all right man like
so i'd never done it before i just
grabbed this thing and and it was just
this big mess of ink and i couldn't see
i was just and then when i wiped away
the ink it said stevo i left out an e
um and uh
and then after that i would tattoo if
somebody just presented me with the
tattoo machine you know like hand me the
thing and it's like oh okay like
um and then as i was doing that one time
during a meet and greet where a guy just
handed it you know
pulled out of the the gear i thought man
wouldn't it be funny if i made youtube
really trying you know really trying to
do a good job
and uh and i got more ambitious first
there was like okay now i'm gonna like
actually fill in the the spaces like
yeah you know and then i'm like i'm
gonna do different colors and then i'm
gonna like do some shading and try and
make like a portrait you know like crazy
[ __ ] and and uh the last one i did was
called jugs judy where it's it's it's uh
judge judy
taking off her
top and she's got a huge titty sticking
out like uh and she's all looking sexy
yeah it's your mag that's your magnum
rufus i'm gotta believe so far
my crown jewel is not that my my crown
jewel
still a raid one
it's still the the video game one yeah
squirt game paid him to do a tattoo on
somebody i did one of these these brand
integrations where they paid me to
promote their product and i was like all
right i'm gonna make a video of doing a
tattoo of their [ __ ] character that's
a show
when you show the world yeah you what
you want to do
the other stuff fall into place
video game show hey
tattoos
i don't play video games but they hit
the number
yeah exactly
and that one uh that one was the crown
jewel because i it was a portrait and i
blended i didn't just do shading but i
blended different colors together man my
tattoo pro like
he
emphatically tried to talk me out of
doing that one i was like [ __ ] i
don't care i'm doing it and it was a win
that's dope how long did that take you
it was like eight six eight hours
we put some time in on that yeah the sun
was down by the end yeah
so yeah that's definitely a
labor of love it's not it's like you
know
it's satisfying when when you get done
and you're proud of the tattoo that you
did yeah but god like to to get to that
point it's an ordeal man it's like it's
not a fun process of doing it and the
last time i gave a tattoo i was like i
had this panic attack like man what if
uh this [ __ ] it gets infected like
for something even though i did
everything pro i did everything
professionally still like you can have
that happen gets infected and what if
someone sues me i'm like [ __ ]
you know like why am i doing this but
then again i can just get stressed about
anything like i'm bad
it's easy to you know yeah something in
the future sometimes
going back to eric andre's show yeah
and like stress and whatnot like you
know that show is very sort of
uncomfortable you know you make the
guests kind of uncomfortable at least
like in a comedic way yeah like you
sitting there are you was that easy for
you were you like oh this is no big deal
like they're uncomfortable i'm cool or
were you kind of like feeling awkward or
uncomfortable a lot of the time
yeah sometimes
because it's
it's not a
it's not a normal way to interact with
people right
well sure and so
and it's you know cut down too right
right right you know what i'm saying so
it's
so
yeah so sometimes those are going
hour two hours to cut
to two three
so you know there's sometimes where it's
just it is really
really weird
or fun
some of my
rapper ninja warrior
was
really fun you know what i'm saying some
of the performances
some of the moments are truly like
exciting in there some of them are weird
as hell
yeah and up and down and it's cut down
and it's amazing right uh but then some
are genuinely you know you look at the
rapper warrior ninja
clip i'm genuinely laughing uh-huh
at that once that's not me faking it i
can't believe this is happening in front
of me and so there's a lot of those
those type of moments too or even that
was one where the guys were hanging
upside down yeah i was there for that
and i was like hitting them with tennis
balls and [ __ ] yeah oh then again but
then again yeah maybe you did that
i think you might have did the second
one did you yeah i think it might have
been the second one yeah uh there's a
rap competition these guys are hanging
upside down having to wrap while they're
hanging upside down and basically being
tortured yeah just doing different
things so that one was i couldn't
because it felt like
you know
is this
what are our what are the legal
ramifications
that this shouldn't be
somebody's gonna get hurt but although
this is i can't believe this is
happening because i a couple of folks
was friends too danny brown was there
and
uh open mic eagles so it was just you
know it was it was that those were wild
yeah when you're hanging upside down you
can't get like you're stuck
yeah yeah yeah and but like would you
ever go up to a someone like after the
show be like hey like sorry i'm not
really like that it's nice to meet you
this is the real me like kind of
uh
no not that much because i didn't feel
that
responsibility as the co-host yeah
that's true because i wasn't the driving
force so i didn't right
uh
i didn't really
yeah yeah i didn't really do it like
that maybe i should have though because
it is
somewhere like oh do they think even if
it is television i win or it was fun
that is you know some people's first
time
meeting me and [ __ ] right exactly in
that context uh
it's a
it's a wild show man it's a lot of it's
a lot of stuff on that that cutting room
floor for joe yeah i mean i i feel like
that eric andre's show
is reminiscent like the weirdness of
like the old tom green show but just so
souped up and on acid like
yeah when tom green was like kind of
messing with his friends
you know like when he was on that set he
would go out on the on the street and
really [ __ ] with rapper but eric andre
is like messing with like famous people
which is like a whole nother level that
like people really upset
i mean they had to have been sometimes
uh
some people saying mora who was really
upset
was lou for rig no
i can't i can picture that i think he's
a guy he's
yeah but i wasn't
because it's
at a dynamic and i'm standing up a lot
too
i'm like
not fully
connected in the experience if you get
what i mean as far as like you're like
the guy over there yeah as far as even
the
the the guests
uh emotional arc too you know i mean i'm
just there like
like saying random [ __ ] uh especially if
i don't i don't know anybody get pissed
and be like you can't air this like [ __ ]
you guys i think that they sign a
release form before they start rolling i
mean that's always your goal so yeah i
don't know because that that's that's
you know on the producer end of the game
and and all of that so i'm not i'm not
dealing with those those parts right
right but i'm sure some people like
uh because it it probably
you know
feels weird afterwards
take a shower
why did i
why did i do that what am i you know you
have to question a few things like it's
it's a it's a weird yeah you know i i
wanted to say this before going back to
the miami night special yeah which was
on youtube but no longer is and
and i searched for it like i didn't
like
there's not like uh
just schmucks that put up the whole
thing you know like it's it's not on
there so
i think that
i'd like to encourage you to put it out
on your own website
with a paywall because that's what i did
and it's why i was hearing so much from
adam about you putting it on youtube is
because i had my own special yeah that i
wanted to put out by myself and i put it
out with the paywall and i did really
well with it oh it worked like uh like
like really well with it i had spent
three hundred thousand dollars producing
it yeah and um
more than got that back i was super
happy
so
we i mean we can
we can help you it's pretty simple to
set up like uh
drive a bunch of traffic
you know yeah for sure
it's uh you gotta you got a website and
[ __ ] i have a website i know i know the
options available it's just yeah i'm not
uh
it's it's not a i don't have the urgency
with it and i i fully produced it myself
too
right uh can i ask you how much it cost
around around that around 300 and that
was the second one i shot too
i shot it
on my own
uh in la
in
was that
january of
january or february of
2019.
i should have done a different venue
spot was cool but maybe not for the
special and then it was some other
was that the miami knights one
uh that was the first version of it it
was called something else then okay and
yeah i shot a version of it
and actually it was some
producer issues
where
the main guy
who who wanted to produce he couldn't
he had something to do that but he had
his team
uh there so he couldn't be there
so his number two was there
and uh
the guy was like hey uh usually we you
know have the warm-up comic
get these shots these pickups of the
audience
laughing like you know that
everybody laughed at how that was cut
away
and i said
that's cool that y'all like to do i
don't want to have that because i don't
want to
set that
energy
i want it to you know feel as natural as
it can and if we're doing that at the
top of the show
it puts the audience in a certain state
of mind right especially when you got
the camera right in front of the [ __ ]
person's face it's always the most
awkward
yeah and like hey now laugh
right yeah and so i say we we had a
conversation a couple times
i say no i don't i don't i don't want to
do that
if the joke obama
that's it you know what i'm saying
like i'm not worried about
like trying to chop it in and fake cut
and so
second show
or you know first show or second show
but
i'm backstage and i hear
the uh
opener
kind of
doing that like doing the [ __ ] like oh
yeah everybody good laugh get some claps
oh dude that's awful and so
i thought that i thought you were saying
get the crowd laughing at the opener's
jokes not the opener saying no
like so he still told the opener to do
that
and it was like
yo you why
this is
we ain't
y'all didn't chip in on this why you you
know what i mean you producing
just
follow that simple direction it's easy
to just not do that that's not what i
right ask for i would not well it's more
than easy it's it's kind of
yeah a little blatant and so
with that
in addition to some other stuff i was
like okay
your name can't be on my [ __ ] i will
do this again
just because you
so that's how that's how the number got
up to 300 by the time it was done
because you had two nights of uh
the full but it was just you know i i
redid it one because of that that cause
that i didn't want to have that
marker of that feeling of a [ __ ]
doing something at the show that was
like
like the money you put a price on that
that's that's not enough like no
that's marking the night where you
didn't
do your job and i when talking on stage
i don't want to i don't want to remember
that in that way at least
you go up there and you're just [ __ ]
pissed the whole time
it was
yeah because it's already so many other
things that you're
you're thinking about um
with it that it's tough to to lock in on
the
the performance and that that's one
thing too
with the
with music it's easy to
it's easier to lock in you know what i
mean because
you can
enjoy your own music on your time or
like you could you know what i mean you
could you could work on it
without
the people being there you can get back
and so then when you got the people
there
you get in-ear monitors you know what
i'm saying and you got so you got the
[ __ ] right into your [ __ ] brain
and so when the [ __ ] is going right into
your you can you in there
and it don't really matter what's going
on in the room you can lock into the to
the song in a way
that you can't with like comedy you
could catch that vibe sometimes if you
riff in or something they really roll in
you can have those moments but it's it's
tough to like
constantly have it and it's work to
constantly have it versus like if you
like your songs and you believe in your
[ __ ] and the shit's right going into
your brain
it's you could be in a whole
in a whole nother world when you when
you there was was comedy like exhausting
you like were you over comedy i could
feel that i was that in it you know what
i'm saying like i was up there you know
and i didn't i wasn't
i wasn't like
it wasn't it wasn't joyful and so
you can't i can't be in that that zone
because it's not about the
like yeah i couldn't like keep doing it
especially with what people
pay for my tickets i can't just be out
there like
you know
half-assing and that's where i felt like
i was doing i was just going out there
so yeah it was just you know
shifting in and and
yeah the music's a rebirth yeah yeah
that's cool and was it like uh
overwhelming almost i guess like the the
sort of popularity of it and with movies
and [ __ ] like was it like is it a relief
to be sort of starting
back at like
zero with music you know versus like
you know the comedy had got you like
such a
i don't know so much notoriety and the
movies and everything
it's a
yeah it's like a
you can just
it's just his differently man just to to
be able to
just capture different [ __ ]
in that way
work on it and
different topics all types i talk about
you know playing basketball
playing basketball i talk about ball and
talk about veneers talk about you know
i'm able to reflect on
things in my
comedy career addictions
gambling in a way
where
some of the songs are funny but i don't
always have to play for that that laugh
or i could you know
you could use detail
and and other things being specific
about without
you could have you know
i just uh
yeah just to you know enjoy it in that
in that way
and
yeah
who don't i might get back into it at
another time like fully so it's not a
but it's just
it is this thing because like you know
you know
and especially in this phase
that's
you know where the
what people
have seen
and know you know
okay we know that can make money but a
dog hey come to a
comedy like so it's like
it's having is having is having a
conversation over there no i want to do
meals to get that [ __ ] like hey can you
come to him like i don't know you want
me to do some songs
yeah yeah i'll give you some strong
banters
i ain't trying to just come talk that
joke can you come to that
i don't really want to come through and
tell it
uh but it's it's you know one of the
bits in the the
video i watched last night was you're
talking about
going to
a riff raff concert yeah and how he
had his dj playing his songs in which he
was rapping
but he was just sitting there listening
to his own music yeah in front of a huge
audience yeah and you said man that
sounds like an easy night twerk i'm
gonna try it right now and you had the
dj play your own stand-up and you just
stood there listening to your own stand
up and said uh-huh yeah oh yeah the
pickle juice like that yeah
yeah exactly and uh it occurs to me that
you know the way that
yeah i do i do the comedy and i do the
stunts and i've mixed them together into
this multimedia show i gotta believe
that it's that you don't have to be
forced to be oh am i here to do comedy
or am i here to do music like why not
marry your worlds together and just have
it be like just a night of entertainment
absolutely uh absolutely i think it's
and it's you know it's an internal thing
more so than anything versus you know
any real
forces
it's more of a
uh shifting identity you know what i'm
saying i went right oh because i've been
doing
i started doing stand-up when i was 19
you know i was and i'm i'm 39 so it's
just
that was the so did you start to resent
the pressure of like come be the funny
guy
not the pres it's just i think you not
the pressure of it just burn out it's
just like when you go up on stage now
for music are you nervous and excited
and like [ __ ] excited yeah also too
right now you know what it is i didn't
want to end up
doing
i it was like i love the the ideas that
i have from from parenthood i feel like
if i do instead of now
i would be getting into
dad mode too
of it i mean and that's that's also a
choice or decision too but that's where
a lot of the the new stuff will be
coming from i think that that's great
too
i've got a bit about getting a vasectomy
and
when i do it i find myself thinking man
getting a vasectomy i
i'm a uh
sort of um
limit if i had kids i'd have all this
great material from having kids yeah and
i got a vasectomy that just kind of
you know but you got material from that
too that's true you know yeah yeah and
it means just me overthinking all the
time but
yeah i i'd be interested in in
in your dad mode comedy yeah it's love
that
it's a it's a
it's a it's
it's dope seeing uh seeing the growth
yeah seeing her you know she just turned
one yeah but then again dude there's
like
there's the
there's some comedians that have
like old material about their kids and
now their kids are like 18 and and kind
of like wait a second
you know like big j had a
like a bit about his his daughter
cutting
holes out of her underwear he's like why
is there holes in your underwear and she
was embarrassed of her skid marks and
actually took scissors and cut right
which was a super funny bit yeah but i
think his daughter's like 18 years old
now right
yeah you got to like grow with the kid
the material has to grow with the kid
yeah yeah that's yeah where's like you
don't want to you know right
yeah it's like i got this one-year-old
joke but now i got a four-year-old yeah
yeah is it oh and then yeah you could
all go particularly
with the kid i'm talking about the kid
being horrified about the existing
material about them yeah yeah that's uh
that thing would stand up where
you know i became more
conscientious of it
earlier on
because it was jokes i've done about
family just thinking like have fun right
and you find out folks mad you find out
do you think you're like oh man so
it does kind of
on a on a personal level make you okay
is this bit
worth
like that is it is it worth that just uh
to entertain in that in that way you
know what i mean like oh foot is this
person's uh
you know versus you know
maybe in 2011 2012.
uh
didn't think of that time i was like
whatever happens [ __ ] that's the
set this is life
whatever anybody can get it god damn it
right now it's like well you know as you
can you could write from wherever you
could come up with so you you know it's
more
uh
consideration
and uh right and i remember you know and
you know in music you could use
metaphor
a little bit more and yeah and that
could be subtlety and and multiple
meetings on things you could you could
hide stuff a little bit where
uh and you could protect people a little
bit better while still
yeah how long does it take you to write
a song
depends obviously but
it uh it appears yeah like
sometimes quick like boom i got it one
day
like uh
uh one three pocket
was
part of a freestyle
that i did in hawaii in november
2020 when i was i was really high
and just kind of it was beat by kiefer
who's really amazing producer and i
rapped over one day then i
the next day i went in
wrapped over it again
wrapped about 14 minutes or so
and then
used part of it for the song kept about
three
and then it was a part where i got in
like i heard myself
you know i started talking about bowling
yeah
you had a straight ball with me hit the
one three pocket in the [ __ ] so late
bills are out here with the strike so
cold and i've been bullish just like
seven years old and i'm rapping about
bowling i don't give a [ __ ] you
hear the [ __ ] swag yes real
[ __ ] and i i was filming that
session too
so i looked back at the the tape
i was looking back
and i saw
i saw my body language while i was
saying that [ __ ] it was like i really i
was like okay i meant that [ __ ] because
i
you know i had my eyes closed while i
was just so it was all
for written so
then later on like
you know earlier this year's when i
started i had the ideas i played that
for somebody like you need to lean into
the bowling thing so that you know the
foundation was set 20 20 then earlier
this year like okay let me take that
sample from that one three buy it and
then you know then wrote it really
quickly
originally was that a written bit
no that was uh it was a freestyle and
then you know this took that took that
segment
and then when i was in new york got to
new york
early i took a trip in uh late january
early february and that that trip kind
of really energized me too i was having
a tough time at the beginning of the
year
and that getting back there because i
hadn't been there in a minute and moving
around and working there
uh on music was really energizing
and so
did the first verse of it
at this studio uh mansion studios uh in
uh in new york
and we just kind of really hyped about
it uh this guy wasabi poppy did the
drums on there and it's always dope to
collaborate cause some people will bring
something from a musical yeah
that i would never i wouldn't have done
those type of drawings for sure they
should they did not and uh
and so then we just like listening to it
over and over
and then
i took the rough i knew somebody at the
pva i was like i got this bowling song i
was hyped about it
i was like
i sent that [ __ ] to them like five in
the morning send it to a bunch of
friends
just to ruffle one verse and then
i had a session
uh with static selector later
and then you
we hung out did it started a few songs
and then uh we went to the club and
i hadn't been to a new york
club in a minute it was weird as hell
you know the bottle service and [ __ ] i
haven't done but
at one point i was like
i air i look up on airdrop and just
just sent it to everybody who airdrop
was hoping
and i sent it one of the people was the
dj and i guess he knew i was there with
static i don't know but he did it and
then he played it right away in the club
and it was just dope to
[ __ ] have the [ __ ] moved at that fast
where you know finished recording it
like four or five in the morning sitting
in a club
you know i met with my friend from the
pba talked about it she gave him some
ideas
uh and then
in the club
air dropped it to a dj
and he played it
right away and it didn't ruin the club
obviously they don't know the song but
nobody was like hey what the [ __ ] right
so it was just dope to see that [ __ ]
move that fast like that
how is it labeled like for for the the
djs it like i think it just comes up
uh
like hannibal wants to hannibal wants to
air drop something you know so he said
like hannibal's phone or something like
that
you should stand outside of power 106
and air drop big boy
for real
it just shows that you know you could
just hey all people could do is say no
uh but that would that felt because
sometimes i sit on stuff too long over
the song rework it
and then that that showed me that if you
hey if you want to you know press the
gas or whatever yeah you can do it
however you want to do it so that was a
really that was a dope weekend being
back in back in new york and just
getting getting [ __ ] moving yeah that's
like some jay-z [ __ ] you know just like
go play it in the club see how it goes
you know yeah it felt it felt dope man
like having [ __ ] like i didn't set out
to make
club music and [ __ ]
but
it's just dope when you when your [ __ ]
i'm not performing in the club right
[ __ ] just playing so i mean it's a solid
the song works yeah without anything
right to do it with me and so that [ __ ]
it's pure uh yeah [ __ ] felt great that's
good that's awesome man
um
what's your uh do do you have a favorite
way for people to consume your music is
it like spotify itunes like wherever
they want to uh yeah all little it's up
on all of those on the s youtube
uh and then when you say s youtube
e-s-h-u-t-u-n
s-u-tune
yeah s-u is uh i was trying to come up
with a
a separate uh like i was trying to come
up with a stage name or music name
uh and then
i didn't find it at first i thought of
this one wabanzia joe which is wabanzi
is a street um
in in my neighbor old neighborhood in
chicago and joe is kind of nicknamed
like
chicago slang
man it's joe what's up joe joe everybody
joe and so that was but it didn't like
hit like that and then i was trying to
find something that really really stuck
so i looked up
nigerian
i look up african mythology
and so they have their different
uh
gods and orishas and and
and
esu is the trickster
guy inside it's all these diff and so i
really connected with the
you know
all the the the lore around that
as she was like the loki
of african mythology like that okay that
archetype and so it just that just
clicked and was like
and uh
and then it made it really easy to
separate and compartmentalize you know
because now i can i view it versus like
before like okay am i going to do some
comments though i'm going to put out
and then now is i can view them as
separate
separate things where it's like
this guy is
helping out this guy
this guy needs
you know
as you needs hannibal to
get him in the door you know how to say
he's still growing and so it really
helped from uh just because i'm
you know distracted and all over the
place so just having them you know
the pillars uh
just yeah and then you know going
forward it's a bunch of other stuff
around where i could write and
you know
kind of world build based on on that
type of thing so it's uh
yeah i'm hyped man and the su tune is an
actual album
yeah it's the it's the name and it's
that the name of the first project
that's youtube yep right okay okay so
we're gonna tell people again it's
e-s-h-u-s-u
tune yeah
and it's available on spotify apple
music yeah youtube everywhere yeah is
that
like what
with the music industry and all the
changes that's happened like
that like is streaming is uh do you have
like uh
like like i know on on youtube you got
adsense and you see like the the is it's
kind of like that oh yeah they have the
uh apple music and spotify for artists
right where spotify for artists shows
you
like if people were listening right
there
where they listening from and then apple
music will show you
like who should where where somebody
shazam was this kind of ah
it's kind of nice like imagining those
scenarios oh somebody in uh serbia
what was going on there
so many people used to talk about when
the first time they heard themselves on
the radio they were driving in the car
and they pulled over they're like yeah
and now nowadays it's like the first
time i
got pinged that i was shazamed yeah yeah
oh somebody in charleston girl south
carolina just uh shazam but that's like
double cool because that means it was
like somewhere yeah and somebody wanted
to hear it so it's like double level
both yeah it's interesting to see it
because also sometimes you know the
stand-up
audio you'll see that it was like where
was my stand-up playing
with somebody
yeah somebody was like let me shazam
like where
what's the contact with that i do like i
like
backstories and wondering the situation
like people just listening to stand up
at the crib that's that's also beautiful
too but it's just uh
yeah it was just there like stand-up
bars but yeah it was just like some
cafes and just listen to stand up like i
used to work at a restaurant when you go
into the bathroom they would have comedy
planes so somebody started taking a piss
like oh [ __ ] that's funny you didn't and
she's hamming it you know yeah
yeah it's uh
it's a crazy world man yeah austin used
to have
um maybe they still do but they had
stand-up radio they had a stand-up radio
station terrestrial yeah for a while in
austin and i remember going there and
being in a taxi
and
somebody recognizing my voice
the driver recognized my voice but
didn't know
what i looked like at all but they just
heard me on the radio he's like you are
you animal birds why oh you said and
that's how and it was driving a lot of
ticket sales at the time and [ __ ] um and
that was always that's always wild too
when people don't know how you they like
oh you sound familiar
do you have any uh
any other [ __ ] that we haven't talked
about that you want to promote like
uh send people to your social media yes
yeah you know check out the mute i'm
starting to get the music videos
together and so that's going to be on
your youtube channel which is hannibal
burst animal burst and uh yeah man i'm
just yeah i appreciate y'all coming
through dawg this is like this is this
is
hella cool and
you know
that it fell together like this you know
with y'all traveling and moving around
and and
it's cool to
you know right after a show on a
hangover too
you know this is
the dopest post show thing usually it's
just you go get some food or some [ __ ]
of just like
sit with it or like
[Music]
something
we always want to have like the dopest
guests like we're pretty snobby about
like people like you know what do you
think it was it's always now we don't
want that but now when your name came up
we were fired up like it was automatic
like [ __ ] yeah we're not even supposed
to be in milwaukee we took like a
[ __ ] three-hour detour to get to you
so appreciate you you know uh yeah yeah
you know we were super stoked to talk to
you man hell yeah man this was awesome
i flew out just to do this podcast
yeah i appreciate it yeah he did yeah
cool people
thank you so much for this bro yeah man
for sure thank you steve man
yeah dude here we are again man i
want you guys to know that i really do
appreciate you
sticking around to the end of the
podcast and i got to tell you too that
today was a gnarly day
actually to peel back the curtain a
little bit today was the day that dave
england came flew in to tour
we just got back from the skate park man
and uh i am all beat up dude
skateboarding at 48 years old
sucks
but you do not ed thank you so much man
i love you guys
[Music]